No, not at all. about his presence on LSF. Oh, oh. Well, somebody
said in chat, I don't know if it's true or not, but somebody
said that he literally said verbatim like Destiny is controlling
the narrative or he was saying that Destiny was controlling the
narrative on LSF and stuff. Cuz there is you had a lot of people
that saw you in favor before all that stuff came out and now
they obviously don't.
Okay, so is there any Wait, Destiny might be your Would you rather
have a lolic on jerker by a moderating a subreddit? It's one
or the other. You have to pick one or the other. Ooh. don't Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Reddits is like an auto kick thing or Fact
of the matter. I asked you, would you rather have a Nazi or a
lolic on enjoyer moderating a subreddit? Here you go. Back on
shut up.
Uh hold on. Let me pull this up. All right. I think there are
groups of people on Reddit that are I'd rather have a lolic jerker
than a [__] Nazi dude. That's like my favorite subreddit.
Uh well, I I'm No, not at Oh, he's complaining about his presence
on LSF. Of uh If it doesn't have like certain requirement, it
gets deleted. Um so they're one like all content on there good
or bad. Go back 60 seconds. Okay. But his community doesn't really
post there Okay, so then so then did that stop on January then
I guess so I don't have that anymore. So it's all of my threads
are being downloaded. no. Well, I I if you if you're looking
for a reason of why we're you're seeing half it or zero, basically
some up votes, some down voted,
um I would say that's why. Cuz there is you had a lot of people
that saw you in favor before all that stuff came out and now
they obviously don't. Okay, so is there any possible way that
I could falsify your claim? Cuz I can demonstrate activity on
my subreddit, activity on my live stream viewership, and then
I can show you zero up votes on every single LSF thread. I don't
know how I can possibly Well, we we'd have to get the LSF vote
threads then see how many are up voted and how many are down
voted. I'm sure you could just ask Stale. People don't
little predators. What else needs to be have too few down votes.
Uh well, I I'm No. No. No. No. That doesn't happen anymore. We
took that rule out of uh Oh, it's the Tibbles guy. This is the
Tibbles guy, the LSF mod. on that one, or do you think it's because
there are other communities and maybe even xQc's that doesn't
like Hasan that then jumped on to upvote that cuz it was attacking
Hasan. Well, yeah. I I mean, that's I don't I What What are you
trying to get at this? Like That I don't have any special control
or huge community influence on LSF in some way that nobody else
does, that there are just a lot of large fighting communities
on LSF and No, hold on. This isn't This isn't Aak. This is Tibbles.
This is the LSF mod,
Okay. But you don't you don't think that um that Stail being
this
openly supportive of you, he also does the pretty much all the
actions on the
on the I think that that can be cause for concern, but then you
would just have to demonstrate at least one I've I've to But
cause for concern, you have to demonstrate one example. What's
the thing that was removed that you can think of? This is just
a millionth [__] LSF bias argument. I I'd have to
go back, but again
There's no way this is how No, I'm just I'm just You don't have
to give an exact example. I'm just curious in your mind.
Oh, but don't you Don't you remember how he doesn't care, Qman?
He doesn't care. Don't you remember that he doesn't care about
LSF?
He doesn't care about LSF. Not that it matters. LSF Not that
it matters.
Or in Southern Sun's name, not that it matters. Rose is uh this.
Got him. I forgot why it got removed initially. It got removed
for a low effort reason initially. Then with Reddit's new rules,
um they changed the moderating rules on Reddit. So, if someone's
post doesn't get through a couple times or if it gets caught
by the auto mod, every single post after that
then gets removed. Okay. So, initially that happened with this
post. We dealt with it. Are we We're just going through all of
LSF's rules? Then he kept Wait, should we Should we go back and
just uh start Should we go to the VOD and start
I you guys might remember it. Um a post about Hassan talking
about Stale and another mod approved it. And we we kind of tried
to clear things up in the the post itself, but Stale got really
pissed about that, of course. I Is Arc like is Arc from like
miles away talking? He has no no communication no leadership
Why? What's wrong with his What's wrong with his leadership?
What's wrong with his communication?
Well, I don't things like based on facts. It's all based on on
how he feels in the moment. Any example? I can give you an example.
Okay, so the past moderator team, he accused them of doxxing
him. Maybe. And this is on the This is on the same thread I was
just talking about. Accused him of doxxing him. And I said, "What
Where did they doxx you?" And I asked him to supply proof, and
he last week did with Stale. What were the issues? What were
the issues brought up? Tell me. Uh he makes you Oh, not good.
Um at this point In the In the past In the past, I've been a
moderator on LSF for 2 years. I've been contacted. I can tell
Well, it's okay. He's going to get He's going to get a lot of
views from DGG. It's fine. That's I I know because of some LSF
stuff or was it just like I don't I don't I don't know I shouldn't
be asking this. Or was it like a personal thing? Uh we don't
know. I I we don't know. what the comment is.
How are we getting this far away from about it. Yeah. Kind of
hard to to gauge it as a Destiny, he's not good anymore. Destiny,
are you are you in? There we go. There we go. Okay, what's up?
Um so, Destiny, do you control LSF? Do you Do you think you have
the most viewers on LSF? Yes. Yes. Oh, this is
Dude, why would you run this stream and be like such an open
uh sorry, like right off the panda. Uh it's actually [__]
crazy. Well, it's fine. Uh explain. It's fine. It's fine. It's
fine. It's Oh, Massa Destiny. Massa Destiny. Welcome to the stream,
Massa Destiny. No, I'm just kidding. I don't What do you mean?
I have an active fan base? Oh, are there other fan bases? I disavow
that. I disavow that.
You got You got You got the mic. Talk to Like this is Okay, I
can't tell how much like people are honest with things versus
how much like people are um I'm not accusing Tibbled of lying,
but I feel like streamers play this weird game where they pretend
that they don't know what's going on, but I that but I feel like
everybody knows. This is my perception of how LSF works. You
have like the four nations of like big LSF communities. And this
has kind of changed over time. You have like OTK, you've got
the HasanAbi heads, you've got the Miz kids,
and then you've got like like Destiny fans, and then I guess
like xQc. Guys, not that it matters, okay? I don't really care
about LSF that much. I only comment there, I only talk about
it often, I only get super ass mad all the time about how my
comments get And at any point in time, there were these like
five huge groups, and then depending on who was fighting who,
you would kind of see like the subreddit sway in that direction.
But I don't know if there's ever been a time where like one of
these communities have been big enough to like compete with multiple
other communities if they start fighting. So right now, for Redacted,
I'm never Why Why doesn't Destiny deal with the fact that like
his biggest clipper to LSF hates him because of his conduct?
Like that's That's where Destiny's problem start and stop, right?
Is that the biggest clipper of Destiny thinks he's a complete
piece of for doing what he did. very popular internet. So most
of the other communities will downvote my stuff, but if some
big event comes up where xQc and Hasan get into a fight, and
I decide that like oh, I think xQc was in the right here, like
Hasan, he's a piece of [__] Well, then like the next
few Destiny posts that show up are going to start magically getting
upvoted, but it's probably going to be because the xQc guys are
going to stop downvoting my or they'll upvote mine or Hasan's
going to upvote it, etc. Just like that. I feel like that's how
LSF has worked for the past like five or six or seven years.
Okay, so you're saying it's basically a battlefield, right? Of
all the biggest streamer com- I don't know How does Destiny not
include himself in those like quote unquote nations or whatever,
right? How is there not like a DGG nation when he openly brags
all the time about how he is the biggest subreddit on Reddit?
Am I crazy? Am I nuts? Yeah, and whoever's like like the alliances
at the time. Like there have been times in the past where me
and xQc have been fighting, and then like Asmongold and OTK and
like xQc heads will come and nuke my [__] And then
there'll be times where we're like we're more like on each other's
side for a particular drama or thing, and then for a while after
they'll all be like There's no way he like visualizes this all
in his mind. On on Well, I think so he's basically visualizing
himself as like partially this is explaining why he's a victim
here. I do think he spends almost all of his time in his mind
as a victim. You'd say it probably goes back to some victimization
of childhood. I'm not going to get specific, but I I assume
Okay, Tibo and He spends a lot of time thinking about how he's
the victim now. I Yeah, I I I think overall that's a fair assessment.
Yeah, that's So what's your Well, I think that the issue with
with Stale and this might not even be Destiny. I I I I doubt
this is a we talk about Stale, let's let's let's stick to we
got to get to Destiny's in here, right? I'm sure he's busy. Let's
let's let's let's cook Destiny first, okay? You want to cook
him? You got you got to want to cook Destiny. I don't have a
I don't have a a problem per se with
Oh, I was Okay, you want to cook his
How old was Rose? What up? capturing the subreddit. What's the
problem with the audience Why do you No, I I don't want to cook
him. No. I'm I'm just saying what is going what is going on?
What is going on is that Stale is a clear supporter
of Destiny. He always has been. He openly is. So if you're a
fan of a streamer, you can't moderate a Like okay, I understand
what you're saying. If Stale was actually like being like being
a [__] like a mod who doesn't cover up for OTK and
Asan, I wouldn't care. I would agree with you. But he does he
he covers up for the big Some people are concerned or confused
about why I said possibly some victimization of childhood. I'm
actually just talking about what I heard from Nato Erudite that
Destiny was like neglected as a kid and that that makes him like
a victim and that explains a lot of his behavior now that he's
used to being neglected. That's it. That's all. I just I want
to make that confusing for anybody, okay? He's a victim of childhood
neglect. up for the the big boys because he wants to be though.
He doesn't. I I True Tequila Sunrise. Yes, brutally
He's a star [__] He wants to be friends with him,
okay? He isn't. If he's come The only people I've ever seen him
cover up for is Destiny and
and Do you think Do you think Do you think Stail covers up for
you? And give an honest answer. This is a This is a This is a
thing I have never talked to him about this and I don't have
any information about this, but I would be willing to bet $25
that without ever looking Okay, I would bet one
A $25 bet from Destiny. Damn, that lawsuit is scary as hell.
Dude, 20 Dude. What? Dude, 25
dollars.
In his defense in defense in his defense, he's probably asking
for almost the entire life savings of a Reddit moderator, so
I'm pretty sure sure. Okay. And there's only so high you can
go with a bet. As LSF has requested takedowns on threads more
than me because I've requested zero and my guess is at least
one of those is about How much did you get from the river stabbing?
I forget. 100 bucks.
You're a thief, bro.
um than I have cuz I've never talked to Stail about ever taking
down any of that ever. Uh with the possible exception of when
stuff started leaking, somebody might have contacted me. I don't
remember if he did or not, but I said like maybe like if other
people's names show up that their so their stuff doesn't strive
there. That might be the only thing, but that had to do with
other people, not me, but I've never told him to like delete
any comments about me or anything like that ever. So if something
were getting deleted about me, I don't know why. Stail's not
like an active member of my community, so it's not like he's
getting a bunch of like free clout or favors or Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. I remember one of those screenshots that would be
very help very uh helpful. He's not an active member of the community,
he does watch every episode, okay? I watch every episode of anything
else. So I mean, I don't know. Maybe he's not an active member.
Apparently, he watches all the podcasts though. or anything like
that. So if he is like I can't believe this is just a whole 'nother
debate about LSF bias. It's actually like mind-numbing. I don't
Maybe I'm I might just be losing it. Uh
It's I think the the way to look at this is not that it's a debate
about LSF bias. It's just a debate about like Destiny coming
on to complain. He's just He's basically just asked Matt that
he gets downvoted on LSF.
That's like the entire pretense behind
but I don't know like I would say Stale definitely likes you,
but he definitely like moderates it in a way where
he doesn't protect you. That's my opinion. That's just my opinion,
bro. Like I've been watching it like I'm not trying to hate on
you or fight you, but like it's just obvious, bro. Like it doesn't
reason why when you there's like 1,000 upvoted comments saying
LSF, you know, white control or OTK controls this [__]
and then it gets removed like an hour later. Like you guys see
all these comments, right? And then but the fact that you wouldn't
bring that up is very concerning cuz then it's it's it's basically
like you see those comments and you just completely ignore it,
throw it to the wait. I'm ignoring it or know the LSF mods.
The OTK Oh, yeah, cuz I guess my cuz I feel like there's a really
easy thing to prove. I feel like it's just what comments have
been removed that shouldn't have been removed that seem to show
favoritism to me. And then under those rules, like what comments
should have been removed that weren't removed? That'd be my have
any of that information to
Um I would have to go look I've I've only gone through like half
of my videos. The one that pops out was uh the What's it? The
Stay Safe thread where Stale deleted all the proof about Stay
Safe being a white supremacist. And literally the only comment
he approved is Stay Safe is based.
You know what? Is Stay Safe like my friend? I really don't what?
This guy just hates Arc, okay? Sorry. This guy just hates uh
Stale. He just despises Stale. now Matt Morgan's TV. He was Do
I know this person or does I mean I get that. That Destiny That
Destiny guy really sucks was removed his comment on there. Still
sweeps 100%. I mean I don't I literally don't know what you're
talking about. I'm sure there could be things that No. It sounds
like I think I've seen examples of people getting banned with
like pretty innocuous comments. Oh, no. This has nothing to do
with you. Oh, okay. No. I say it's just an example
A- Again, like I said, I I feel like Stale does stuff based on
like how he feels at the time, not on actual like facts or even
like the truth or or
And he said so before. What did he say? Like For Like what Uh
like with the like with the past mods, I doxxed them. I He said
they doxxed him. Um I provide proof that they did not doxx him.
I provide proof that only two of them really did anything, and
that was message the whole subreddit. And then he said, "Oh,
doxxing uh breaking Reddit rules, same thing." Okay. Oh, wait.
Zizee. Oh, Zizee, you should DM me whatever your theory is. then
I'm like, "Well, can you Can you admit that they didn't dox They're
trying so hard. Yeah, it doesn't come together the same way,
does it? I just I It doesn't come together the same way. And
he's like, "No, well, I I feel like they did, so
So, that that's how it's going to be." Okay. So, I'm looking
at DGG chat and my Kick chat. DGG chat is popping right now.
They They don't They don't agree with you. One question here.
Eat, ask him why is J Stalk and others can talk
and clip chimp the [__] out of Destiny and nothing
gets taken down.
Where did I do that? Where did I clip chimp the [__]
out of Destiny? Famous LSF post that J Stalk who is always making
clips for for LSF.
Yeah, the disgusting J Stalk. I literally played a WillyMac clip
who if anything has been accused of sweeping for Destiny, okay?
And then I commented on it. Where am I Where am I clip chipping
this guy? with that question? Do you think that Do you think
that's happening? On LSF? Yeah. That Destiny's getting clip chimped.
What? Right now? Yeah. Like right now? Um I guess right now,
yeah. And in the past, for sure.
um I can only talk about the past. Um, I don't remember that
happening in the past. Okay. All right, anyways, let's Destiny's
in here. I'm I feel like I'm not getting enough conversation
and he probably wants to leave soon. So, this conversation is
going to be a This is like aimless. This is like Yes, I
But, I'm so glad we're here for this. I want you to like Oh,
hold on. Actually, I should remove Queen Man's thing. Listen,
we have other we have other things, but uh I will remove Queen
Man's penguin thing. It blinks a little too much. But, we know
that we've already fixed the technology has already been fixed.
We just don't need Queen Man as a penguin when we're not doing
penguin mode. So,
let's uh let's get the penguin out. Get the wiggler the quiggler
back in. Okay, we're good. Destiny, I want you guys to like
talk about this thing cuz Tibolt, you did accuse you you do Let
me well, Tibolt. You you think it's run by DGG and Destiny and
stuff. And Destiny No, I don't think it's run. I think they have
a heavy influence on it. Okay, but then the other Well, that's
true of every single large streamer and every single large community,
right? Uh not well, every large community doesn't cover like
com- comprehensively
Destiny's Destiny's Reddit community is like verifiably way bigger
than like every other streamer community. He brags about it all
the time.
How would that not have a significant weight on a like smaller
or not smaller necessarily? Although, actually, in terms of activity,
which which subreddit is even bigger? God, it's like LSF had
a fall off, but then also Destiny had a fall off. So, 2000 Oh,
LSF's way bigger right now. Isn't it Isn't it Isn't it? No, 1600
versus 2200. They're like the same size. Dude, they're like the
same size. What do we How can Destiny pretend that like he wouldn't
have a massively outsized influence on LSF? Live streaming. Like
when when things when clips first come out, they usually go to
LSF. So, Okay, I'm sorry. Let me clarify. Not every single community
through time and space and on the planet. I mean, every community
that has like people actively posted at LSF, like all those communities
are like on like like are big members of LSF, right? Um Like
Asmongold's community probably upvotes his clips. Maybe. I guess
I haven't seen any there in a while. Or OTK's clips. Put the
penguin put put the pen queen back on. Uh no, Jimberly, because
he has donated $10 gets a say in that and nobody else does. If
you want the penguin back, donate money. Probably upvote upvote
their clips or Hasan people or OTK, right? Probably. Um
Wait, do you think my community is the only community that actively
upvotes clips about me on LSF? Uh the No, I don't. Uh the But
I mean the the two biggest offenders are your community and Hasan's
community.
Woah, are you saying this like incredibly hyperbolic thing that
you didn't say? Uh no, but that also doesn't mean that your community
doesn't have a And then why is it that every single like thread
posted about me in the past like 2 months Wait, are you saying
that like I've raped 100 people right now? No? So then I'm not
a Okay. Okay. has zero upvotes. Good. Good. I I I can't control
the upvotes, man. Well, no, I'm not Wait. Wait, is your top gifter?
Do I get a say? Uh Stalin and Sloth, you might get a say, but
I I actually don't like the leaky penguin. To just control who
like what what community upvotes what.
No, no, wait. What what what are you trying to get at? claim
was that Hasan and my community had the were the largest influencers
of LSF, and then my response was how is it Okay. I'm going to
restart really quickly so that we don't lose our place. 2 hours
45 minutes. And then my response was how is it that almost every
thread that's gotten posted to me in the past I guess almost
2 and 1/2 months now, all of them have zero upvotes cuz they've
all been downvoted so much. If my community was so influential,
how are they getting mass outvoted by Well, I mean, come on,
Destiny. You know what's been going on recently. I mean, your
community you you essentially lost your orbiters, lost half your
community, they aren't happy with you. So you have half your
community that like you. Half your community that loves you and
will love you no matter what you do. Okay, so when we say First
of all, my orbiters Well, that's don't have communities. That's
why they're orbiters, okay? Number one. I I would argue they
do. I would especially
Uh Lunar Box is a massive community. What is Destiny talking
about?
Jayslu, or Jayslu. I always forget his [__] So, Jayslu's
subreddit has like five active watchers. So, I don't think about
like five Oh, he's talking about you guys participating on the
subreddit. That's reddit.com/r/jayslu.
Really, it's just me and only Pissy's mute on there, okay? So,
you should go over here and you should sub to the thing, okay?
Only four users here right now? Don't let them be right on that.
Yeah, it's up to you guys go post memes there, post stream content,
okay? I check it every stream. You go ahead and check it out.
500 or 1,000 on Kick. I mean, I know it's not like what what
you get, but it is something. Okay, so you think that the three
to 600 viewers that he gets is enough to overcome the 12,000
live viewers that I have when I'm covering the news every day.
Dude, this is This is actually Listen, again, a dog whistle,
but that's actually such insanely bad faith. I don't know I don't
know why he would say that. Uh I would say Dude, there's so many
like long-term Okay, you you you you you you you you you think
that a small streamer can take me out? Like you No, obviously
you can only cancel only yourself can cancel yourself, right?
Like It's like it's not about the viewership even. It's like
he's getting politics viewers who watch him for his politics
stuff on YouTube who don't engage on Reddit. A lot of his Again,
I'll just put out Dwarfy, okay? I'll just go to Shaw. Or formerly
Shaw Shaw. I don't actually know what you I don't know what username
he uses anymore. But, Dwarfy, this is the guy who used to post
every single Destiny clip everywhere, okay? He used to love Destiny.
And now, he posts like anti-Destiny clips. That's like more what
he posts. He's gotten rid of a couple of them, but uh he like
he doesn't like Destiny. This is the guy who posted all the stuff
to LSF. THAT'S WHY DESTINY'S getting [__] on LSF
cuz the guys who are like ride or die are like, "Oh, this guy's
actually an asshole." And they [__] off.
So, yes, he can maintain his viewership, but the people who actually
loved him, the people who are actually ride or dies, they [__]
off. That's the thing. I I didn't say that. I just said he does
use my that they they they don't No, you said One second, Destiny.
You said that they don't have a community. And I'm saying they
do have a say I didn't say they don't have a community. I said
that they don't have a community that's like large. They're orbiters,
right? By definition. I'm not being mean, but like definitionally,
they don't, right? Uh I would argue they
Or or gaining one now. orbiters have All my orbiters combined
you think have a community that is about the same size as mine?
I No, I didn't say that. Please stop. Yeah, yeah. I'm just trying
to understand how if my community is so huge, how are we having
zero upvotes? You You have lost half my community. Where do you
see this evidence at? well, I can't be so big. Yeah, I get zero
upvotes on your subreddit. Dude, what is this conversation like?
People love me so much since it came out that I don't respect
women's consent that it's baffling to my mind that I could possibly
be downvoted on LSF. Like, there's no way that that anybody who
dislikes me could possibly go and downvote me on LSF. It just
It's impossible. Dude, I just don't even like why is this even
a conversation? I don't
It's Like, there's a lot more people that hate Can't you appreciate
it? There's a way that it works, okay? More people If more people
press the up arrow, it gets positive.
If more people press the down arrow, it gets negative. Now, if
you have more people that hate you than people that like you,
the chances of that number being positive are lower. We Have
we We can move on now, I feel like. Let's Destiny, can we I feel
like Let's Let's wrap this up now. Dude, and like when he has
good clips, they pop off. As as Elibabba just put, okay? When
when he has good clips, the one where he was like, "Oh, Hasan's
obsessed with me." and he like clicks on the Hasan's thing and
Hasan's talking about him. That got like massive upvotes. That
was on the front page for like a day and a half. It's like, dude,
you one, one, you fell off, and two, people don't [__]
with you no more. People don't like you. I'm sorry, people don't
like you. What else what else needs to be said other than like
people just don't like you? it's sure the engaged
drama, you know, type people have a very negative They used to
have like a a middling, sometimes negative, middling opinion
of him. Go either way, really. And now they have a significantly
negative opinion. That's what the engaged drama viewer type people
think now. Let's look at So, yes, when your Reddit posts pop
up, they're more likely to be negative. Look at permission winer
winer. Okay, permission winer posted a Destiny clip to LSF. Destiny
is a recipe for free money.
This is this is zero upvotes. It's minus
Uh never mind. Actually, I changed what I'm saying. Never mind.
Turn it is actually 100% correct. If you have a really strong
Uh turn it Destiny, by the is going to move in some direction.
It's
free money. You're guaranteed
like you're not going to have to pay a premium for it. You should
just buy as much of these derivative into these derivative markets
as you can, and you're just guaranteed to make a [__]
ton of money. Nobody's pricing anything accordingly. Your current
knowledge is only explanation for why this clip is not on the
front page of LSF It's actually only explanation for why this
clip is not on the front page of LSF is literally that there
is a conspiracy against Destiny between many communities to keep
him off the front
That could That clip was so good. I can't Dude, it's just a conspira-
It's clear conspiracy. Oh my god. What a clear conspiracy to
keep this guy off the front page? a softer affect on stream these
days. Am I crazy?
M- Uh maybe. I don't know. You're guaranteed
like you're You're going to have to pay a premium for it. You
should just buy as much. I don't know. You're correct. Your knowledge
is right. Hard to say. It's free money basically. You should
probably just borrow as much as you can Yeah, hard to say. Hard
to say. Hard to say. You got a You got a theory based on that,
Kman? That he's got a softer affect? Oh, I was just I was just
Uh it's Just commenting? Okay. All right. From what's like who's
not watching you anymore, who's
made comments saying viewership is is generally higher than it
has been in the past cuz I've been covering a lot of new stuff.
My subreddit is about as active as it has ever has been, maybe
a little bit more active. I lost some subs on YouTube. My But
I mean Lost some subs on YouTube. He's been covering nothing
but politics, his bread and butter. And I hope I I think I don't
hope actually. [__] this guy. But maybe maybe
this week for the first time ever he will break into positive
YouTube subs for the first time in forever. Like what? Where
is this half of my community has left? Well, they may not have
even left, but would you agree you have
Cake Cake used to have When Cake still worked for him, okay?
Cake used to have these dashboards, but I can't [__]
I don't have the dashboards anymore. I would love to see cuz
there is somebody tracking it like the month over month DGG viewership.
I actually don't know that for a fact. I don't know that for
a fact. Hold on, I just said something that I don't know for
a fact. And you'll leave I was told something along these lines,
but I wasn't told for a fact, okay? I don't know for a fact.
I used to I used to be able to see dashboards of like chatters
and stuff. But yeah. He's had since the thing happened he's had
zero weeks. Not that he had particularly good growth before the
leaks happened. Right? Not that he was like doing particularly
well before
Barely growing at all before this, but he has yet to have a positive
week. He has zero positive weeks so far. Zeros and minus however
many thousands. So
or people that did like you before don't like you because of
the
I don't mean, want to throw this out, the whole s- Okay, that's
okay. Um I I'm sure there are people that don't like me, sure.
But I mean I mean I don't see how that helps your argument that
I have like control over LSF. Or are you saying I had control
over LSF until I got into a bigger argument with you had control
over LSF. I said you have a great influence on LSF due to stale.
Wait, you said I had you said I had a top two community influence.
Me and Hasan were the top community influencers on LSF. Correct.
Yeah. They're the two biggest as far as streamers are concerned.
I guess you can consider Ice Poseidon's, but his community doesn't
really post there anymore. Okay, so then so then did that stop
This guy this guy being like this blind to OTK kind of makes
me feel like it's not as valid. I don't know. Well, I think the
problem is that he's not saying he's saying in terms of like
streamers, like individual streamers shots probably true. But
if you count OTK as a collective, then I think that's a whole
different story. Yeah, but like they operate as a collective
is more my thought. Like the a lot of the fan base operates as
collective, so upon January then I Even if you just said Mizkif,
I feel like the Mizkif people were so big on drama for so long.
I don't have that anymore. So it's all of my threads have been
downloaded. Well, no. Well, I I if you if you're looking for
a reason of why we're you're
Remember when you leaked Amouranth coming on the election stream
literally the day after? Dude, I was so exhausted that day and
I told Dan I was like, "I don't know if you should trust me right
now." And then I read it off and I was like, "Oh, [__]
me. I just said I just said the name he sent. Whoops."
Whoops. upvote or zero, basically some upvotes, some downvoted.
Um I would say that's why. Cuz there was you had a lot of people
that saw you in favor before all that stuff came out and I can't
believe he just can't accept that he fell off. I really thought
he was more analytical than this. Well, here's the thing. I don't
know that he like I think in terms of his live stream viewership,
I don't believe he like fell off. I think it seems like his live
stream viewership is surging, but that's because the new cycle,
right? Trump is literally like his whole thing was he was anti-Trump
and Trump is literally like trying to destroy that country. Like
there's a certain amount of insulation he gets just from that.
Fell off is not the right term. I would say I would say people
watch him, but they almost watch him begrudgingly, right? A lot
of people will just be like, "Well, I'm listening to him for
the same reason I watch the news." It's like I don't have to
like Anderson Cooper to watch the news, to watch CNN, right?
I think that's how a lot of people like like watch him now. That's
how they engage overall. And I think that that's the issue for
him is like he doesn't have the ride or dies anymore, right?
A lot of people will just watch, but they don't like care as
much. They don't They're not like the massive fans. They'll watch,
they'll listen to the arguments, but they're not going to go
to LSF and argue that he's like not a bad person anymore. It's
uh it's just different. don't. Okay, so is there any possible
way that I could falsify your claim? Cuz I can demonstrate activity
on my subreddit activity on my live stream viewership and I can
This is like an example here. Uh so I I don't know if this is
like the best example, but I'm going to I'm going to use it anyway.
Check it out. So here's from Here's Veneer a snapshot of Veneer
from uh July 2024.
In this 31 31-day reporting period a total of 9,214
nicks were
uh represented in DGG chat.
And then basically we go down to this last 31 days now last 31
days now is
This is in the core DGG chat, okay? Core DGG chat. So we're going
basically a year later this has fallen off significantly. You
would expect given the news cycle that this would be massively
up, right? I think. Now, maybe you could argue time of year or
something, but realistically it seems like the DGG chat slowed
down considerably at this point. zero upvotes on every single
LSF thread. I don't know how I can possibly Well, we we'd have
to get the LSF vote threads then see how many are upvoted and
how many are downvoted. I'm sure you could just ask Stale. At
At point I don't know if you even can bring them up because don't
they auto delete threads that have too few down votes? Okay,
this is where we got onto the uh what I No, no, no, that doesn't
happen anymore. We took that rule out of if it doesn't have doesn't
meet like the certain requirement gets deleted. Um site wide
like all content on there good or not. So looking at like 6 hours
ago Destiny is racist for free money, zero up votes, 38
I've got I can Do you want me to keep reading or no? Well, we'd
have to go back and compile all the the posts, see what were
upvoted, see what were downvoted over a period of time. Taking
one post now isn't it's kind of taking things out of context.
Okay. Okay, here, let me let me do like quickly and then I can
explain what's happening. I think it's the same thing that's
always happened, okay? So Destiny is racist for free money 2.8
thousand votes for 1.3 thousand comments. So do you think I got
a lot of up votes on this one? This was 26 days ago because I
controlled like the narrative on that one? What do you think
it's because there are other communities, especially like Asmongold's
and maybe even xQc's doesn't like Hasan that then jumped on to
upvote that cuz it was attacking Hasan? Well, yeah, I I mean
that's I don't I What are you trying to get at this? Like That
I don't have any special control or huge community influence
on LSF in some way that nobody else does that there are just
a lot of large fighting communities on LS I think you could just
argue that he absolutely did and now he's just totally And it's
just depends on who's like allied with who at what particular
point in time or which drama is involving which person, that's
it. Okay, but you don't you don't think that
uh Stail being this
openly supportive of you, he also does the pretty much all the
actions on the
on the that that can be cause for concern, but then you just
have to demonstrate at least one example. I've I've be cause
for concern, you have to demonstrate one example. What's the
thing that was removed that shouldn't have been? I mean I I'd
have to go Uh yeah, exactly. He like he dominated LSF before
the allegations came out, right? It's super easy to understand
exactly how this happened and why this happened. IT'S LIKE NOT
EVEN There's no difficult analysis required here. Guy was on
LSF three or four times a day for consecutive weeks in a row.
Right? Leading up to the allegations. The allegations drop. People
don't like Okay? Who Who's Who's confused?
again, we can if if Stail has nothing to hide, we can go and
go and show us. Okay, so I'm just You don't have to give it an
exact example. I'm just curious in your mind like what do you
like what what do you remember or what do you have the impression
of that's been removed that should have never been removed? Uh
well, what didn't get removed was the your ex-wife talking about
the state. That's probably the one that that comes to mind. What
was the removal reason on that? Initially,
I forgot why it got removed initially. It got removed for a low-effort
reason initially. Then with Reddit's new rules, they changed
the moderating rules on Reddit. So, if someone's post doesn't
get through a couple times or if he gets caught by the auto mod
every the clip to be can't possibly be keep going forward. Looking
for anything. You can talk to Stail. If
Stail says I don't show any favoritism, couldn't you just say,
"Well, of course he's not going to admit to you that he shows
favoritism?" Well, I mean, I he can show
what how he's been moderating by showing it. So, the only way
to prove that he
Is the goal here to get the mod to mention his case so he can
say, "Wow, this guy is biased. Wow."
I mean, that kind of It kind of seemed like he was biased before,
to be honest, when he said Stail moderates for Destiny. Like
realistically, it didn't seem like he had a lot of good evidence
for that when he came on my stream. So, I don't know. I thought
that was like a little weird. I don't think that's the case.
I just think Yeah, I I don't I don't know. Show favoritism to
release the full mod log of the entire last six months. Time
You're saying the same thing about me then. Guys are going at
it. Sorry. If you guys were to release all the moderator logs,
would you only release Destiny's version of it or would you release
everything so we can see everything? Honestly, if you guys release
that, you will get so much like grace and it would actually help
so I'm not part of the team. He kicked everyone off once we are
you in here? Still honestly still get the [__] in
here, dude. He's not going to say anything. He's not going to
say anything. He's not going to say anything. He's not going
to say He's not going to say anything cuz he's wrong. How does
Wait, where does Oc get off on doing this? this and then he's
like, "But I'll never talk to this Queen and guy ever."
I don't know about that. I don't know about that. Can he do this?
Can someone explain to me what the the breaking news US 10-year
bond yields rise sharply to over 4.5%
and why everyone's saying that means everything's going to go
get [__]
Can someone explain Uh I thought I the whole point was Trump
wanted to raise bond yields because Was it Did he want bond yields
to go up? No, he wanted bond yields to go down. If bond yields
are going up, then that means interest rates aren't going up
and Trump will have to enact harsher tariffs maybe to get the
outcomes he wants. Maybe that's more it cuz Trump's goal was
to lower bond yields to push people to with the volatility to
push people into bonds. How the [__] are bonds going
Wait, how the [__] are bonds possibly going up?
Is Trump going to turn it around? understand. I don't understand.
I don't understand. I don't
So as more people buy US Treasury bonds, the yields go down because
they can't afford to keep writing so many bonds for people at
like the same rates, right? That's what I understand. Bond demand
goes up because volatility? Yes, bond demand goes up, but bond
yields should go down. As bond demand goes up, bond yields should
go down. No, they should go up cuz more people are buying them
now. Is that how that works? Well, no. The yields should go down
because Okay, I I think the point is that Trump thinks they're
paying out too much in these bonds, right? And they want to refinance
them or something and turn them to like 25-year or indefinite
or something. Is that Is that correct? are uh
I wasn't listening. I was reading your chat message. I'm sorry.
Can you say that again? The The whole theory is like
the idea that Oh, refinancing debt. Yes, refinancing debt because
as yields go down, then that's the the yield rate is like the
I think the ceiling on the interest rate or something. The ceiling
or the floor on the interest rate. As yields go down, then the
interest rate can go down. Bond yields should go down,
I believe. Uh so, bond yields shouldn't be set by the Fed in
the same way the interest rate is. Are they? I heard China's
unloading bonds. So, if China was unloading their US bonds, then
that would have this effect. Yes, but I I believe bonds when
bonds when things are volatile, people go to bonds cuz bonds
are safe. They They they give you like a uh a consistent yield.
But, when more people buy bonds, the yield should go down. The
The interest rate is determined by the rate the Fed puts on newly
issued bonds. I thought that the bond rate could change I thought
I thought bond yields could change
based on like they were flexible. And the the interest rate when
they moved the basis points on the interest rate, like the Fed
determined interest rates. I thought that was something they
do each quarter. So, maybe not. I I don't have a prob- I don't
have a problem I need Turnabout or Marty Epstein. Turnabout,
Marty Epstein, either one of them. Let's go. You guys are required
now. Hello. with Destiny Destiny is not the problem. Well, you
have a problem with We're not It's Okay, that doesn't that doesn't
really matter. You have a problem with this community messing
up your sub Reddit, but in my opinion, that's not true. No, no.
I I I have a problem
No, no, no, no, no, no. You're I have a
with uh Stale and him having such a heavy influence from the
GG community. I don't think one streamer or one group should
have a head mod. that influence show in like the post and the
comments and stuff? I don't see it like that. I don't see Maybe
it wasn't a pa- Even in the past, bro, like GG dude Okay, I don't
I know like I know all these online communities, bro. DGG is
like the most online, it's a pretty big uh So, China is retaliating.
Okay, China is retaliating. My interest rate and have an inverse
relationship with bond prices. Yes, that's what I thought. community,
what? Destiny average is 10K plus. They're the most online, they're
like coders, they're older.
There should be no way I'm muted. every big streamer has that
kind of community, it's just different version. Like Hasan's
are like the, you know, Yeah. young, you know, Hold on, you said
you were a moderator on LSF before? Yeah, 2 years. For 2 years?
How many requests did you guys get for me to take down any threads?
Oh, none. None. How many requests did you get from Hasan?
Zero. Really? Not a single request? Uh no. No, I can't The only
requests we got were Mizkif, we got a lot from Casey
Um All right. Right. Oh, stay safe.
Not You'd be surprised. Hasan doesn't
I was in the old LSF Discord. You were, I think, cuz you wrote
that unhinged message about me before you left. So, you guys
made that Discord? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Not gay. Were you
Go off, Quimby. I'll be right back. Oh, it's it's fine. Why My
headphones won't I'm just taking shots. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. What? There was a Discord where you guys invited like all
the major streamers to unique individual channels if we had a
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, that was
the mods before. I might have just got invited on. I remember
that happening. That was like the first week I got invited on.
Okay, okay. So, so yeah, I know you're talking about. None of
those mods are there anymore. Okay, so you said Mizkif and Casey
Tron. Um has Mizkif been like DMing you recently or like is that
like a stop doing No, Mizkif Mizkif like 10 times, and he still
DMs you guys? That's crazy. He's got a mental illness, then.
Well, it's funny, his friend DM'd me, like his friend telling
us to take down uh Yeah, he does that. a thread that had his
had his last name in it. Then when I looked up the clip, it was
the guy messaging me saying Miszkif's last name in the clip.
So I was like Yeah, I was like, are you And that's the like he
he does that too. He'll he will he will DM himself, but he gets
like his moderators, his workers, or whatever to like do do that
as well, do his bidding. Um he's very good he's very like He's
been doing it for years, bro. He's very good at it. Yeah, that's
the only time You guys know why Destiny's on here,
Do you Do you You understand why Destiny's on here? Well, not
really talking to these people, just hanging out. He just wants
to get DGG to go and support the stream. He said, "Listen, he's
got he's got some streams in this time slot he's not a fan I'm
ever heard from Miszkif. Feeling salty? So it's So you're saying
Miszkif Okay, I want to show you something real quick about Miszkif.
Are you feeling salty today? doesn't really have any control
I'm good. on LSF.
Go and try Try I want somebody to do it to do something right
now. Say something negative about Miszkif on LSF. Come back in
10 minutes and show me the results. Show me the like upvote downvote.
And uh well, and you you got You got to watch out certain words
and certain things that automod catch. no no no no no no. Say
Miszkif sucks a lot, okay? And then come back to me and tell
me what the results are. Automod. Come on, bro. Stop. That's
not funny. I disavow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. If you You don't appreciate racist talk bad
on Miszkif. Anything Miszkif got saved It's just the most obvious
Asian like American Asian voice I've ever heard, you know?
I'm not going to I'm not going to go into it, but it saved his
career. Um No, I I agree. Yeah, completely. And he knows it.
He's aware. He even thanks his audience for it. Um and the LSF
Wait, wait, wait, I'm sorry. Miszkif said what saved his career?
Uh LSF and his an army of Russian cyber warfare autist. Jesus.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, anyways, I don't think LSF even had I think
LSF is just like a mental health debuff. I don't know if it like
makes or breaks your Everyone Everyone on the internet is mentally
ill, like And you read it every day. different level. But realistically,
this mental illness Dude, it's a I don't care about all this
stuff. I will come on and argue about how LSF is like how it's
up that my clips all have zero upvotes, but LSF is a mental illness,
okay? If you care about that, you're mentally ill.
Amazing. Amazing.
Just like 40% of something in the country. I think it's literally
like 80% just half of people won't won't admit it. If you're
not mentally ill, you're not saying Apparently, Dan may join
shortly. Dan. You're doing something wrong. In fact. Once I got
on ADHD meds, my life I need that [__] bro. You guys
saw how I'm streaming Oh my god, here we go. The GG classic,
the ADHD meds. This is crazy. Mana Vyvanse, mana of the gods.
I was diagnosed ADHD, but I've never taken the meds. It was uh
Yeah, like the peace in my head now is indescribable. I I've
taken Adderall before. I know how it feels. wow, this is really
riveting stuff. I love this conversation. Anyways, um so anyways,
back to what I was saying about Mizkif and whatever. So, you
can't say anything negative about Mizkif. Now, this is just the
greatest example. I don't want to go searching, but like Teccy
called out Mizkif. But, Miz
he had to go and ruin Yep, that's that's a that's like common
knowledge. Oh, look, it's it's in Destiny. r/destiny
All right, so we got some some of those leaked DMs. Let's check
them out. I wonder I wonder why I wonder why it would be in r/destiny.
Crazy.
So, this is the stuff from before. This is the previous mod team
that this guy already said it was the previous mod team. I don't
know about that. They don't do that anymore.
So, from 2021, we're going to get the OTK stuff from 2021. Based.
I I do I do think your community I think you have the largest
influence on LSF because of how stale views you. Okay, but we
have no evidence of that.
I I not that I could pull up right here. Okay, well, we This
might be how my stream started. Yeah, I was not very good at
streaming when I started. is my counter evidence which It's changed
a lot now, okay? Things are very different now. I'm very good
at it. There's the fact that for the past two or three months
I've been getting exclusively good on by the way. I I I wouldn't
call that evidence. Well, what does it mean to control a subreddit
if the entire subreddit is constantly posting about you and raging
against See, I don't know if this guy Did this guy say control?
It's like an influence. He has an influence over the subreddit.
Well, if the top mod can freely approve and remove whatever post
he want, then don't you think that's
Well, if anything then if I were to argue that that's control
then that means it still hates me because he lets really horrible
threads about me stay up. I'm pretty sure there's Well, I I really
horrible threads about me stay up. Like when I When I say people
need to be killed. When I say I want people Yes, those are He
lets those stay up. That's horrible. I think he loves his top
mod position more than he loves you. I can see that. Okay, so
again we're in the world of
Well, you're Well, you're asking me evidence that's to the contrary
of everything you're saying. You're not giving me evidence. I
am. You said that I can No, you're not, Destiny. You're you're
you're saying up votes and down votes on threads significant
influence over the subreddit, why why would that top thread stand?
Couldn't still just delete it? Well, again, like I said, he cares
about his top mod position What is that How would that threaten
his top mod position? Because he's not going to willingly just
Dude, what Dude, there's no sign that says they don't rent to
black people. What do you mean they don't rent to black people?
Show me any proof. They don't have a policy that says that says
they don't rent to black people. What do you mean? Uh get the
[__] out of here. Hey, get the [__] out
of here, guys. He can't do it. Destiny has more integrity for
his mod position than he does for his like for me which means
Exactly. Exactly. Well, that But then that's a defeated Sorry,
that's a joke is it like obviously you don't need to be overt
in how you would control or influence something. You can be very
covert. You could just be at the margins sort of like shape things
slightly and that would still over time look a certain way.
That's what this guy should be arguing if he was going to argue
this and it should be all unfalsifiable. He shouldn't be making
falsifiable claims on that, but
I'm just saying that the idea that just because Stale doesn't
remove the claim about Destiny threatening people with violence
is just very clearly him threatening people with violence. That
doesn't mean Stale's not helping him out. Although I don't necessarily
think there's any proof that Stale cares. People The reason his
threats are at zero upvotes is cuz Destiny is people don't like
That's yeah, sexual predators. That's it. Peter for your argument
as well. That means He's not sweeping for me because he likes
his top mod position too much. Well, no. No, he's still influenced
by you. And no way will he take any actions to help me. Well,
no. Well, not like every single action. No, cuz he wants to keep
his top mod position. But we can't name a single action. So then,
okay, then what can we do to make that reality happen? How can
we make LSF Stop posting. Stop posting on LSF. Stop posting on
LSF? Yeah, and choose another subreddit. You've already stated
how much people care about Destiny's degeneracy. Well, he's not
at like 0% or minus he's not at like 20% upvotes. He's at like
41. He's just about breaking through despite the sexual degeneracy.
Yeah, I'm I'm skipping forward quite a bit, guys. on LSF.
I'm looking for apparently Dan talking A lot of them were children.
Quick Does children play That's that's like the least surprising
thing I've ever Too much, right? Maybe they get to Oh, Dan joins
and then they start talking about Dan Clancy right away. Like
you guys Wait. I could never have predicted this. Dan joined
and they immediately start looking at Dan Clancy stuff. Is it
Reddit who is No shot. That's like the least surprising thing
I've ever heard. You know what I'm saying? Like No shot. What
What do you mean? What are you talking about? When did you lose
your mod privileges? Oh, about 2 years ago. 2 years a mod for
Okay, yeah, got you. So, the good guy Dev is the guy who did
livestreamfail.com
and he was supposed to update the revenue stats every month of
what he was going to do, but he didn't. He stopped. And even
when he did, okay, I noticed Dan brought this up on my stream,
too, and I'm like, I don't What do you want me to do about this?
The guy who does the archive site doesn't post the revenue. I
don't know. What What are we supposed to do? that there was a
lot of ads that were not showing up in the revenue stats for
that. But, that was something that all of you guys were happy
to let go, and that was before Sale. So, I don't know why you're
complaining about whatever. Who's that annoying guy in my ear
now? that they have now when Jesus Christ. 10 times worse. And
on this mirror site that you guys had before, there was no DMCA
thing, okay? And if you think about all this clipping that is
literally just what we from people's streams. own the mirror
bot. Someone Someone else owns it. like basically fully endorsing
something when you allow only one bot to post on to every single
post, and everything else gets removed? That kind of endorses
it a little bit. Wouldn't you think? I agree. Okay. Yeah. So,
maybe you shouldn't [__] talk about whatever's going
on now. Dude, there's no way This is not what my stream was like
ever. This is not what my stream was like. Stop. Stop. When you
guys oversaw way [__] worse when you were there.
People are saying like this is what my stream used to be like.
This is not what my stream was like.
I wasn't there either. Sale was there a lot longer than I've
been. Top mod? Sale? Cuz you're blaming him for there. I'm I'm
confused. Are you trying to say I was a mod before Sale? No,
I'm saying that why are you coming at Sale for something that
was happening when you were there before he was the head mod,
and you had nothing to say about it then, but now it's a big
deal? Well, I'm I'm saying that's I'm I'm not saying it's a big
deal. I'm saying that that might be a thing. brought it up. I
am assuming I'm I'm only with the Kelly in the background talking
about it being boring. Cool. Well, I'm saying that's why these
groups these groups of mods are collecting subreddits for the
monetary
that that was happening when Sale wasn't the head mod. Who was
the head mod when all was that was happening? Who was the head
mod before? I don't remember. It might have been Felipe.
Okay. So, who was getting paid there for letting the livestreamfail.com
bot? Is anybody even tracking with the argument it's supposed
to be here?
I don't know. What are we doing? like LSF stroll session. LSF
bad. Dan Clancy bad. They never responded to DMCA's and everything
else. I don't know. Like I remember that like some mod mails
went into their saying that like hey you guys Okay, we'll try
to skip forward a little bit more. That as an example. The Yeah,
that that that was happening when Stale was MCA and I think that
you We're getting on to some other topic here. So I guess you
guys didn't care too much, right? When did this happen? About
like maybe a year and a half ago? Yeah, that would have been
like you got to understand at that time I would have like had
no influence on the team. People can not convince me these guys
aren't taking notes on So would have Stale too. He would have
Right, dude. I don't even Well, actually at this time um Stale
wasn't any mod but but you were with him and then you should
have known I don't even know what the arguments
You jerked off the kids. It's fine. Don't be embarrassed about
it. You tried
You sneak it back. Wait, that's not why we were doing Would you
rather have a lollycon jerker by a moderator of a subreddit?
It's one or the other. You have to pick one or the other. If
you don't Hold on. Hold on. Reddits like an auto kick thing or
what? Let me back. Fact of the matter, I asked you would you
rather have a Nazi or a lollycon enjoyer moderating a subreddit?
Oh [__] I won't want either. It wasn't enough for
It wasn't enough for us to post a Destiny clip for Octav to deal
with. It Apparently Destiny's going to come out himself. He's
going to come out himself and defend this. Oh boy. me try this
again. If you had to pick
Okay, hold on. Don't moralize and answer the prompt with a simple
question, okay? You can either have a Nazi No, Destiny I want
I'm back on Destiny's side. Destiny one.
e-con enjoyer I'm not I'm not I'm not answering that question.
Stop moralizing, stop responding that way and just answer with
either Nazi or lollycon enjoyer. Would you rather have a Nazi
or a lollycon enjoyer? Neither. You're a coward. You're such
a dude. I People like you actually destroy the [__]
planet and or at least the internet. How can you not even answer
that question? Are you that much of a [__] spineless
He can't Are you kidding me? answer the [__] question.
Would you rather have a Nazi or would you rather have a lolicon
jerker uh moderating a subreddit? It's one or the other. You
have to pick one or the other. being around a lolicon defender
like this. This seems a little bit strange. Oh no. I thought
lolicon defenders I thought lolicon defense was like the reason
he wouldn't talk to people. With a lolicon defender? That's disgusting.
he's doing backflips right now. He's doing backflips.
No I'm putting files on a table and you sit down. I I also have
to say there's 10 of that table. So all of you look a little
bit sus to me right now, okay? Why bring up Destiny clips? Why
bring up the Destiny clip? And also you want to keep the family
away, okay?
It's actually so funny that everybody's like, "Why would this
be relevant?" Obviously he doesn't like Destiny. Obviously he
doesn't support the stake for Destiny. And then Destiny comes
on the stream and argues in favor. Listen, what's worse? A lolicon
or a Nazi? It was like, "Listen. Listen, man. They're coming
after lolicon, okay? I know we've had our differences, but you
need to go you need to go on and just rate these guys." Oh. You
get both. If you say neither, you get both. No, I can't believe
such a [__]
I can't I can't believe you're getting this mad about it. No,
I'm getting mad because you don't give a [__] about
either thing. You don't care about any of it. It's all a virtue
signal for you, but you're sitting up here pretending like you
give a [__] You should be able to answer that question
super easily. Yeah, I did. Neither. That's not a choice. We live
in a world with Nazis. This is the mod. The mod's getting cooked
by him. And sometimes you got to So which one do you want? Do
you want the Nazi mod or do you want the mod? Or the song try?
The lolicon enjoyer mod? Which one? want I don't want [__]
either of them. I just don't want either of them. Sounds like
a Hasan viewer. I feel like you got a problem with this. This
is just like a question. I don't I don't know why I don't know
why you're making try to pick. Tell him to shut up. Tell him
to shut up.
Where did his energy go? Wait, what what did he say? WAIT, WHAT
DID HE SAY? He said, "Shut up." I actually don't I don't even
know what he said. Hassan viewer Shut the [__] up,
Kelly. Let me hear what he said. I got to hear what he mod or
not the guys very quiet. Which kind of enjoyer mod? Which one?
I don't want [__] either of them. I just don't want
either of them. Sounds like a Hassan viewer. That voice crack
was brutal, by the way, from the mod. Here. I don't know what
the [__] is going on. I don't I don't know why I
don't know why you're making me like try to pick one. Never mind.
It's like it's a it's a very So stupid. It's It's not stupid.
I'm just trying to see like like if you actually Oh, that's rough.
That He's cooked. Yeah, he's cooked. He's cooked in like in less
than 24 hours. What what happened? Oh, yeah.
Uh he just tried to speak like three different times, and they
all talked over him. bail out on the mod the mod, I think. He's
just like the uh what do you call it? He's like the mild mannered
Asian kid, okay? He's getting mild mannered Asian kid syndrome.
NOW, THAT HAPPENS TO ME, but to be fair, when that happens to
me, it's Kelly Jean sperging about something. As I realized that's
a force of nature, okay? You could easily cut in
He got cut off by the right mod, okay? He's He's remembering
getting shouted at for his math homework not being right. rookie
signal because you're some closet who wants to anal some kid.
Like this is a super easy question. It's a super easy question.
He wants to click over again. It is. It is. He just did it. Yeah,
he just did it. He just did it. He He watched that clip, and
he's like, "You're the pedophile." If you've got a problem with
all the comments, you're the pedophile. Oh, Destiny cooked, it
turns out. moderating, or do you want the lolly enjoyer moderating?
If you can't answer that because you can't even Hold on. Hold
on. Apparently, we missed the part where Destiny says he's fine
with the lolly con enjoyer working for him. Hold Uh what? No.
What the [__] back to back tomorrow, dude. It's going
doing back flips and somersaults. There's no way. This guy got
like a Well, I think I is the stupidest What? most dishonest
What? loser
[__] on the face of the internet. This guy is beyond
belief. This guy's [__] six ways in Well, let's let's
find the clip first. Let's find the clip first. Let's find the
clip
What I listen, I'm just fine with like, "Hey, a bunch of people
are like, why did YOU THINK THIS CLIP WAS RELEVANT of Destiny
saying that lolicons okay?" And it's like, well, cuz in the first
stream back in the first stream Wait, I didn't we didn't like
him because
he was only brought in by Stale to just have someone there to
be on his side. He didn't do anything on the subreddit. He didn't
help in any way. He Why they don't like the guy? That's the only
reason why he was there. It's the only thing he did. Okay, so
you guys went through all of his [__] to try and
like track What happened was I was kind of memeing with another
uh mod which is the guy I was talking to in
and I was make kind of making fun of him about how he doesn't
do anything and he's just there to another sub subreddit collect
and the guy I was the moderator I was talking
It was blurred, the one he looked at. Oh, I see. They're uh That
was all blurred. He just he had a
Yeah, that one's not blurred. That one is not blurred.
No, it's it's whatever. He's not pulling it up. He just pointed
it out. So anyways, so when I was talking to him, the guy had
a bad feeling about him Put his
Hold on. Hold on. I think it matters because they're saying Stale
wouldn't I just skipped past it. Yeah, just if the guy watches
lolicons, is that what we're talking about? We were trying to
figure out every single reason Here it is. the more it became
Does this guy watch lolicons, is that what we're talking about?
Yeah.
Wait, so what's the So he does. So this guy, is he still a modder?
No, he got kicked off. Well, then why does this matter? I think
it matters because they're saying Stale wouldn't get rid of him.
Yeah. loli is that are you allowed to mod a subreddit? Is that
like an auto kick thing or what? Well, they have kids. Who's
modding So she has kids.
DUDE, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET ANYBODY TO
MOD A SUBREDDIT? Kids are Well, Destiny, what's your take on
lolicons? Yeah, what's your take on lolicons? give a [__]
I don't know. Why does this matter? I don't know. I'm just curious
what your take is on it.
Oh, no.
Oh, no. Oh, no. No. No.
[__] weirdo. I don't I don't think you want somebody
like that on your moderation team making decisions for like the
whole livestreaming community, right? I mean I guess, but I would
say I wouldn't want anybody from like a ton of different parts
of Reddit that are probably making decisions. Like I wouldn't
want anybody associated with anything having to do with any of
the political Someone's got to do it, right? So we want Yeah,
that's fine, but I would rather have a guy that jerks it to [__]
loli than some dude that posts in some [__] tankie
subreddit. Like I think that that like ironically like I think
there are groups of people on Reddit that are I'd rather have
a a loli This is This is where Erudite gets her argumentation
from, okay? We need We need the same heart in the Democratic
Party, but uh the the guy who likes Palestine, [__]
that guy. Hassan? No, get him out. Get him out. I'd rather have
I'd rather have I'll take it. I'd take Hassan over a Nazi member.
Yes. Yes. Yes. That's just To be honest, if I had to follow up
next to Gremlo, I I get it, okay? All right, there's an argument
there. I'm not writing off To be fair,
and Gremlo, Gremlo is like 5'2. He's basically a child himself.
That's kind of a match made in heaven, isn't it?
Uh hold on, let me pull this up.
Nazi dude that's like smart and
Nazi moderating? Then I don't know. No, we don't we don't have
a Nazi moderator. We don't want either of them. We don't want
either of them. I said that when I asked you a hypothetical question,
you responded with a fact of the matter. I asked you would you
rather have a Nazi or a lolicorn enjoyer moderating a subreddit.
What do I think a Nazi's going to do? I'd probably pick the Nazi.
Realistically, most people aren't posting their their race or
anything online. I'd rather have the Nazi. I'd get rid of both
of them, but I just rather have the Nazi. Sorry. I don't want
either. How come anytime there's a lolicorn debate, Destiny gains
like superpowers? I'm going to take a brave stance here. I am
actually taking a brave stance here. I think I would rather have
the Nazi over the
I think but I think I'd rather have a tankie, too. I think just
getting like if one of your mods gets caught grooming a kid,
Yes. Yes. The absolute downside just with the Nazi versus the
Yes. Yeah, the the total downside is obviously lower with the
uh Yeah, with the Okay, let me try this again. If you had to
pick one, okay? Hold on. Don't moralize and answer the prompt
with a simple question, okay? You can either have a Nazi or a
lolicorn enjoyer moderating a subreddit. I'm not I'm not answering
that question. Stop moralizing. Stop responding that way and
just answer with either Nazi or lolly con enjoyer. Would you
rather have a Nazi or a lolly con enjoyer? Neither. You're a
coward. You're such a dude. I People like you actually destroy
the [__] planet or at least the internet. How can
you not even answer that question? Are you that much of a [__]
spineless [__] You can't Are you kidding me? No,
you should answer the question. Would you rather have a Nazi
or a I'd rather have a lolly con jerker. A moderating a separate.
It's one or the other. You have to pick one or the other. If
you don't choose one, you get both. If you say neither, you get
both. So you get both.
Uh Dan, would you rather have a Nazi or a lolly con jerker working
for Dats? Go. Is he answering that question? No. No, he's not
answering that question. can't I can't believe you're getting
this mad about it. Here, hold on. No, I can't believe you're
getting this mad about either thing. You don't care about any
of it. It's all a virtue signal for you, but you're sitting up
here pretending like you give a [__] You should be
able to answer that question super easily. Yeah, I did. Neither.
That's not a choice.
Crazy. You live in a world where there are Nazis and And sometimes
you got to So which one do you want? Do you want the Nazi mod
or do you want the mod or not the I'm sorry. The lolly con enjoyer
mod. Which one? [__] either of them. I just don't
want either of them. Sounds like a Hasan viewer. Here's the real
problem.
So Destiny's never being on another arc stream, right? Those
voice cracks are good. Destiny's never being on another another
arc stream, right? Well, I've heard arc doesn't like talking
to people who defend lolly con. So I don't know. Yeah, he's not
coming on again. We'll see. I don't know why I don't know why
you're making me like try to pick one. It's like it's a it's
a very so stupid. It's it's It's not stupid. I'm just trying
to see like how like if you actually give a [__]
about any of these issues or if it's just like a virtue signal
because you're some closet who wants to anal [__]
some kid. Like this is a super easy question. It's a super easy
question. Do you want the Nazi moderating or do you want the
lolly enjoyer moderating?
We had Destiny give all these vivid descriptions of things like
sucking
eating [__] Swallowing [__] revelations
about him. And then we start
you want to anal [__] a kid in the anus. children
Hold on. Can we get a quick check on those rose logs? Was he
talking about any ass play with bros pattern other than his own?
Can we Can we get a Jesus. If you can't answer The projection
thing. Oh, by the way, you watched the end of that clip last
night, right, Qwiman, when he talks about how it's so funny how
like the people who talk most about women's rights end up get
end up getting me
You saw that clip, right? Yeah. That because you can't even talk
about the subject. Then why are you up here virtue signaling
so much about it? You're a Why does that matter? You're a pedo.
Yeah, that's fine. Don't be a pedo. I'm sorry, what you're a
Oh, everyone calling someone out or pedophile. No, no, no, no,
no, not pedophile. I'm sorry, not Let's stop. Let's stop the
child battle. Let's just chill. Let's just chill. Yeet.
Is this the same yeet?
Mhm. So, do you do you understand what Destiny's saying though?
Like he he just he thinks you're virtue signaling. And I'm not
going Dude. Oh, wait. Sudan, that's an excellent point. I've
heard that these people complain about the term e-
Surely e- is a massive problem, but just calling somebody a out
because they don't want to work with a with somebody consuming
lolicons. That's totally reasonable, right? Isn't it?
Wow. Hold on, let's listen. Listen to regain control of the back
on track. I understand it's very you know, but like So, do you
do you understand what Destiny's saying though? Like he he just
he thinks you're virtue signaling. And I'm not going to lie,
I don't care about the lolly Nazi. But I do Wait a He doesn't
care. He's not really a pedo. He's
He doesn't care. He doesn't care. Qwiman set this up. Qwiman's
pulling strings. How was this possible? is Do you ever feel like
sometimes you're like in the Truman Show and life is set up just
like specifically for you? Like something that could not possibly
happen is unfolding just because it's like something involving
you. That's how I feel right now. Well, it's it's all it's all
that impossible. It's just guy's like the most manly man loser
[__] in the world. you know.
He's just totally out of himself because he he's just so upset.
why would you have all these people arguing this? And like, some
people messaged me this morning, okay? I got some messages this
morning like, "Why don't you think this guy's a Destiny fan?
That's like so crazy. You're like totally making things up right
now." And it's like then this happens and I'm like, "Well, okay.
All right. All right." a little bit. I don't cuz because I I
don't know. I just think you're purchasing a little bit. Okay.
But I also do think you you want to get rid of the guy. The guy
got rid of him. He's gone. And now I feel like you want a little
more. But like what more do you want now? No, no, no. I I I was
I just Am I crazy? Was Ahknaton kind of pushing Destiny being
like, "Wait, but they just don't want to work with like a like
a Logan Contor?" That's not weird, right? I thought he was like
on the other side of this trying to get Destiny to like come
to the mod side. And now he's like trying to get the mod to move
back to want to talk about it. That's what I thought was going
on over there. in here saying this guy that no one cares about
from 3 weeks ago Guys a bozo. uh LSF moderator uh or can't moderate
other random subreddits. I I just feel like there's more to the
story that you wanted. Cuz we were getting a lot of stuff in
the beginning, but um Someone's got to help this guy. demeanor
or whatever changed. And I get it, bro. Destiny and [__]
Dan, like they're being very you covering for him? I'm not covering
but like bro, it's it's got to be scary. It's not a scary thing.
You good, Kenny? You good? No. He's getting put in this place.
Exactly. That's what I'm saying. He's getting put in He's getting
the leash. He's getting whipped. He He whipped into shape. I'm
happy J Soc isn't like this anymore. Don't you remember when
I argued that Paragon wasn't a cesspit because I had a I had
a pretty good argument there, okay? I wasn't like this from the
beginning. demeanor or whatever I'm telling you. It's different.
Destiny and [__] Dan like they're being very are
you covering for him? I'm not covering but like bro, it's it's
got to be scary. It's not a scary thing. It's a super easy question.
Would you rather have a Nazi or a Would you rather have a Nazi
or a Would you rather have a Nazi or a Would you rather have
a Nazi or a Would you rather have a Nazi or a Would you rather
have a Nazi or a Would you rather have a Nazi too mean to him
and like trying to expect him to be some like super streamer
who can just answer everything perfectly. It's not It's not a
perfect There's a super It's not a difficult It's not a difficult
question. Well, okay. He doesn't want to say those words and
he doesn't want to be clipped. I Well, they answered the question
If you don't want to if you don't want to say it, then why would
you come up here and and talk about the issue at all? You're
not equipped to do it. Then just leave it to somebody else, or
just make a Reddit post or something. I don't disagree. I I just
thought cuz you sent me so many messages and like I don't messages,
but like you sent me so many screenshots of of like the info.
I thought it was like a big story, but basically it's just dancing
on a you know, not moderating random subreddits. I thought you
wanted something like to be done with Stale because you protected
him or whatever you No. Or you wanted you should probably Wait,
is is Yeat throwing this guy under the bus now? I thought this
guy's a clown. That's crazy. That's crazy.
He's like, I thought you had a story here. We covered this and
oh my god, why why did you even message me actually? They ask
people these things before they come on stream to just say
you had like bro, we heard you talking in the beginning. No,
did did I did I what did I did I say any of that You
were like saying that they run the subreddit and [__]
DGG and then you then you like you don't even mention other people
when you like say like I I understand what you I understand you
don't want to you know, look bad, but like dude But why why don't
you show everyone the what I sent you in the DM?
I got to say as a Hold on. Let's let's do a quick investigation
though. Show everyone the what I sent you in the DM. investigation
here. You know what dropped is this way. He literally cropped
the whole left side out. So it's still Dan, Pretty Tony, Meng,
Spriggs, Hamster Hawk. Hamster Hawk. Are there any non Droutslayer
are there any non DGGers in here for a sec? Yeah, are there any
non DGGers in this list of people? Bro, these guys are this guy
is not AFFILIATED WITH THIS GUY IS NOT AFFILIATED WITH DGG. That's
crazy.
That's insane to suggest, guys.
I got to say as a certified mod destroyer, okay, who's taken
out another mod before, this is Here you go, Dan. Oh, he's in
the Daliban Discord,
Amateur hour right now that I'm seeing Tibble. You got to get
your game up. I just feel like Tibble like came in your little
strong and then he got kind of like, you know, the not cool,
but like people were being mean and then he kind of just shifted
his like overall like what he was going to talk about. Well,
I I I think you had a perception of what I was going to talk
about. but yeah, I think What's your take on it? So, bring Tibble
over. We got him over. You got Tibble on our side now, you know.
Tibble was always in the Discord, yeah. Tibble was always Yeah,
he's Well, somebody said in chat, I don't know if it's true or
not, but somebody said that he literally said verbatim like Destiny's
controlling the narrative. Or he was saying that Destiny was
controlling the narrative on LSF and stuff like that. Well, I
thought I think it was the question controls narrative, man.
I should that you he sees that so
Uh what does it What does IT I'M JUST DEFENDING MYSELF. WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO CONTROL THE NARRATIVE? WHAT IS any anyone Everybody
says this is narrative control. I'm controlling the narrative
and I said if anyone is controlling the narrative, it would be
Destiny. But again, I don't think I like it either. What are
the Wait, what's the narrative I might ask you to come on stream
if you're down. Yeah, for sure. Don't mind, just let me know.
Sounds good. Were
you a moderator 1 year ago on that subreddit?
I I What I You You want to repeat Were you a moderator 1 year
ago on that Um what on which one? LSF? Yeah. Uh yeah, I've been
mod a year ago. Somebody linked me a video of myself watching,
I guess, a thing about a year and a half ago where Hasan messaged
you guys to get every Tibble, Tibble, you got to get these voice
cracks under control, okay? These are not okay. single thing
about him remove from LSF to get him banned from LSF. Were you
a moderator at that time? Yeah, but well, at that time I was
I was I was I was Why did you say earlier that he had messaged
you guys? Why'd you say Uh what you said earlier was there was
about a week overlap where he was in the Discord where they had
the contacts with those people to them not being there anymore.
messaged you guys have anything removed at all. You said zero,
lied, you? Because at the time they had uh like junior moderator,
regular moderator, senior moderator, and I was a a junior moderator.
Because
I didn't cuz I didn't see it. I wouldn't have seen it. These
guys literally weren't listening. He literally said like oh the
Discord where that happened where they used to have contacts
with the individual creators. Oh, he didn't say anything about
um Wouldn't the answer to the question have been I don't know
rather than saying no? Couldn't you have said I don't know if
anybody asked for things to be taken down because I don't have
access to the information instead of confidently saying no? Wait,
can't you admit can you admit right now that you lied when you
said you knew for sure that Hasan didn't ask for anything to
be taken down? Please just say yes or no. Did you lie? Yes or
no? Yes or no? Yes or no? That's not what I said. I said in my
time I've been there. Um these are those are the people that
asked for things to be taken down. But that's not true, right?
You just said that that's not true. Hasan asked somebody that
was over your head and you didn't know that. So why would you
just That same thing you just said was not true, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Did you know? Did you know that
Hasan asked to get removed? Um when I first came on the team
If if that was true One day ago before this conversation cuz
we asked you if Hasan had ever asked to be removed. So the answer
is did you know yesterday
before this conversation that Hasan had asked to be removed from
live What is this from?
No, cuz I've never seen it. I never saw
Is this anyone Somebody's saying oh it's Hasan versus Destiny
drama. I want to do like a temp ban on it. What does this have
to do with anything?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. That sounds super confident. I mean you'd have to go back
figure out who was in charge of the team at the time a year and
a half ago. That's I I don't even know how many mod teams and
then they'd have to
What's up? Why was Hasan asking this I didn't get it. He's not.
This is them saying, "Oh, this is like Destiny Hasan drama again.
I don't know if I want to do this." who I was.
I'm pretty confident this is just a mod Yeah, supposed it LSF
mod discussion about Destiny. a hot tip, okay? Next time just
say, "No. [__] no." cuz I said no. And then people
are like, "Oh, right. My bad." But I I don't know if there would
be anyone there to to collaborate in this stuff. So, I don't
think so. You totally knew that Hasan asked to be removed from
Livestream Fails. You're caught and now Dude, don't you feel
bad like sniffing Hasan's taint this hard? Like I don't doesn't
it feel awkward? It's called Doesn't this feel awkward like to
to like so desperately be getting this guy to like denounce Hasan?
I just feel like it's a little crazy to go after it this cover
yourself up and I bet there's proof out there and we're going
to get it. Then you're going to be like, "Oh, I Well, if if there's
any proof out there, I welcome it. Yeah, get get get the proof.
Like what? And why does it matter? Because you're in here saying
that Destiny controls Livestream Fails. say that. You're lying.
That's what you're saying, though. All of these other [__]
kick people that you guys suck are the ones that are in there
saying, "Remove this. Can This is not what the content I Do I
have to go watch an old VOD of mine from Rile's channel to prove
that this is not what the content was like? This is not what
it was like at all. please remove this? Boost this." etc. That's
the other [__] people that you guys are doing. That's
a difference. Wait, didn't you literally say still controlled
it and he's mind raped by annoying and I listen, Tybalt is the
one that That Desi Sorry, Dan's been watching a bunch of my stream.
Desi Sorry, Dan, sorry, is going to uh start using cognitive
okay? And cognitively
We don't use or ripped anymore. It's cognitively ripped, okay?
You've had your cognition hijacked by a [__] all
right? my right there. But I think the annoying is that like
if this conversation wasn't happening, then it would just be
a room full of like 10 people all circle jerking about this [__]
pretending that it's true when it's just completely false. It's
so [__] annoying that this [__] propagates
on the internet everywhere. If whether it's this topic or about
50 million other things and it's just like it couldn't even be
further from the truth. Not only could it not be further from
truth, you knew that Hassan messaged mods at the time because
this is a You did. You did because this was a massive drama.
Because this Because you Because you said you were a moderator
and this was a massive drama on LSF because Hassan was intentionally
brigading the subreddit to try to get his stream banned. Wasn't
that like 3 years ago? I thought that was like 3 years ago when
that happened. That was like right when I first joined Maybe
even longer. That has to be like ages ago. They like just don't
understand time. This is like way before this guy joined. To
try to get his whole stream banned from LSF. Are you telling
me that you had Uh Tibolt, just say in chat, like was it a year
or year and a half you've been a mod for? I don't know what Prove
that I knew it, Destiny.
What's your Reddit account? thing that I knew that I knew it.
2 years? I'm almost positive Hassan's brigading stuff was way
before that. Why don't we just look that up? uh well, can I send
it to you or send it to you? Sure. Send it to me, Destiny. Wait,
did this pause? It did pause. My bad. What Oh, [__]
We just reached the end of the time. God damn it. Ah, [__]
That's so stupid. I was restarting it every once in a while to
not have that happen. Yeah. Choose another subreddit. Choose
another subreddit where What's it called? I'll type it in my
chat. Stuff cuz that's what I sent you. I didn't send you really
So basically We have to we have to skip back or somewhere around
When you get to like the last place you refresh the VOD, it [__]
up really horribly and it looks like this just [__]
up, too. God damn it. No. And then people are like, "Oh, right.
My god." But instead you're like, "Oh, I don't know if there
would be anyone there to to collaborate any of this stuff, so
I don't think so." You totally knew that Hassan asked to be removed
from Livestream Fails. You're caught and now you're trying to
cover yourself up. And I bet asked for things to be taken now.
But that's not true, right? You just said that that's not true.
Hassan No, maybe that was where we were. Cuz I said no. And then
people are like, "Oh, right. My god." So I don't know if there
would be anyone there to to collaborate any of this stuff, so
I don't think so." You totally knew that Hassan asked to be removed
from livestream fails. You're caught and now you're trying to
cover yourself up and I bet there's proof out there and we're
going to get it and you're going to like, "Oh, I forgot." Well,
if there's any proof out there, I welcome it. Yeah, get get the
proof. Like what and why does it matter? Because you're in here
saying that Destiny controls livestream fails. not say that.
You guys are saying that. All of his other suck people that you
guys suck are the ones that are in there saying, "Remove this.
Can you please remove this? Boost this." etc. That's the other
people that you guys are doing. That's a difference. I will say
apparently there's a clip from 3 years ago. Destiny says Hassan
should be banned from LSF. Hold on. Let me Let me try to find
this real quick. Where's the mirror? Where's the mirror? Wait,
didn't you literally say still controlled it and he's mind raped
by Destiny? that's annoying and I listen, Tybalt is the one to
receive my wrath now, but I think what's annoying is that like
if this conversation was Yeah, send it to me, too. I don't know
them. I don't know It's like it's like like white fragile crybaby
is like constantly saying like DGG brigades everything when he's
literally watching threads with 30,000 viewers going every single
comment. It's actually insane. That is brigading. Like that is
by definition brigading. Wow. Destiny's uh Destiny has never
cared about LSF, ever. Just never never had concerns about it
whatsoever. Like locked out the children. Here. I'll send it
to you, Destiny. Oh, I'm just talking to myself. Well, you're
going to have to accept it. HERE YOU GO. AH, NO.
NO WAY. OKAY. SO, you sent me this name. What am I doing with
this name again? I just want the username so I can search. Okay.
Here, I just sent it to you. Destiny. All right, I don't know
how you could have possibly sent it to me when we're not friends
on Discord, but But, I sent you a message. Okay, I see.
So, right now we're looking up So, it looks like it looks like
January No, yeah, January of 2022 is when Hassan was banned from
So, that seems like if if this is what they're talking about,
him being him requesting to be banned from LSF, right? And him
trying to brigade to get banned from LSF, then that seems like
that's way before this guy was ever a moderator. That's 3 years
ago, right? I'm pretty I'm pretty confident. But I think the
whole it's kind of funny. The whole point of him de-modding this
was that you Okay, you don't care. You don't mind it but what
No, no, no, no. Does this Does this like matter to DGGers? That
I don't think it will, but like this whole thing where Dan Destiny
and Dan have combined their powers to lose to a Reddit moderator.
That's what's happened here. They've like they've done their
comeback stream of like hopping on someone else's stream to like
confront them to lose to u/DerpinSauce.
Sorry Tibold, not that you're like the worst but like what what
point was that I thought he was going to talk to me about the
N3DS stuff. Okay, well we we talked about it. He's gone.
That's the story. Reddit mod does [__] suck, but
at least he got on. Jesus Christ.
That's like a 2-minute combo. Dude, you got to clean him in,
man. That's really all it was. I You're the one that asked me
to go on. Well, I mean
Dude, I want I'm going to ask everybody to come on. It's free,
you know, content, but Dude.
Did I clean him good or what? by I stood by Kelly Jean as he
like talked about the hemorrhoids of Destiny's girlfriend. You
got to stand by your guests, bro. You got to You can't just throw
them under the bus like this. This is [__] up. This
actually Well, okay, so you don't So basically you don't care
now. You just like I mean it's all right. I told her it was bad,
but like I didn't ban her or anything. I didn't go like, "Kelly,
you You've ruined the stream." and kick her out. That's crazy.
And that's it. We We good then? You good on your on your Well,
there there is something that the Angel account
he the N3DS dude is planning to come back with
like under a VPN and that's what this Angel account saying that
the Angel is this N3DS guy. Okay. No, no, no. I did not say that.
So he's coming So what is the Angel significance then? Angel's
one of the people that was assisting them or in contact with
him uh during this whole time and he's the one They're the one
that told us that he's going to come back or he's planning to
come back with a VPN and start modding again. Okay. That's That's
really the big thing that I wanted to So, the guy the mod might
come back. Watch out. Okay. Well, he will come come back. Is
that Yeah.
So, I mean, I guess if you if you if you're keeping an eye an
eye on him, you can definitely like send me all the info and
I I can bring it up, but I just feel like the story is not even
like a big deal then. I thought it was I was I'm sorry. I don't
know. I don't feel I feel like I Man, that's [__]
up to like not vet this guy's story and just be like, wait, this
is like actually boring, isn't it? I Okay. What are we I was
trying to get more drama. Well, it's interesting because uh when
I went on the on the GTL
SK stream, he was more Okay, you could get the name kinda right.
What the [__] What the [__] But, Tibble,
I will say that's why I didn't message you about any of this
cuz you didn't actually explain what any of the text messages
were and I'm like, "Okay, I don't even know what's happening
here. I got no idea." So, that's why I didn't message you to
come on. more concerned about N3DS, but when I went to you, you're
more concerned about
He's gone, bro. That's all I'm I I'm the one who [__]
made that tweet that got the [__] him gone. Like,
you know what I'm saying? Like Like, I I let the people know.
Like, you're you're trying Like, bro, like
This is how Tibble should be talking. What the [__]
I made that tweet, bro. I let the people know. I did it. I'M
THE ONE.
HE'S GONE, BRO. That's like All right, anyways, I'm not going
to go over that. Yeah, I I I respect what you're trying TO DO
THOUGH. BUT, FINISH THE SENTENCE THOUGH. Finish the sentence
though. I I do. I like the content, man. Well, like you came
in here and now you're saying it's like a big deal that he's
gone. I love this guy. This is such free content right here.
What the [__] do you want me to want me to go and
like get on my knees and say, "Oh my god, he's gone. Let's pray
for him. Let's like what do you want me to do, dude?" Like cuz
you want you I feel like you came in wanting to make this conversation
a little bit more deeper, then you kind of got cooked, then you
changed your opinion, and now you're trying to like wiggle your
way out of it like you won. And it doesn't happen. Also, hold
on. I'm going through your comment history here. You do mention
that clip that got removed about Molina because Hassan posted
about it on LSF and you replied saying I believe that clip was
over 14 days old, which was likely why it was removed. Right.
So, it wasn't still manually removing things. It was the old
one. it but it was posted after that. Yes, when it would have
been over 14 days old. But and again, I said that I believe that
may have not been the case.
And again, it was pushed back because I we'd have to I'd have
to go back and look at it. I like that line. I'm going to use
that one on anything else. I'm going to have to go back and and
think that one over.
I thought we were looking I thought we were looking over the
logs for proof he was at the time that Hassan was missing
the Discord. So, why are they bringing this up now? Because they
realized that Hassan getting banned from the subreddit was way
before this and they they realized that they're kind of cooked
on this one. So, they're pivoting in real
Use the dog whistle from yesterday. [__] do I not
have the clip here? There's no way I don't have the clip.
Ah. Guy almost had it in real time, but Go back and look at the
post and look at the DMs I got about the post from the person
who wanted to post it. Okay, and I see in another comment. So,
you are aware of what Hassan said because you said the new mods
are pretty much all picked by myself. I've personally never tried
to suppress anything for a streamer unless it had been an already
established rule by the sub. Like for example, the last moderation
team had all Destiny and Hassan content banned for a period of
time when I first came on. Yes, that's when I first came on.
They had it all banned right when I got there. Okay, so you were
aware that that Hassan content at the very least or content between
me Dan is in DGG saying Hassan is 80% view bots by the way. Okay.
And you were aware that there were bans in place because of this.
Well, not Well, not because specifically what you're talking
about. The reason why they were banning Destiny and Hassan stuff
is because they just didn't want to deal with it. is so slippery
here. He was aware he said he said um his argument was Hassan
didn't message them. He didn't He was aware that um Hassan's
stuff was getting taken down. But his was like, I didn't see
anything of um Hassan messaging The the whole accusation was
Hassan messaged you guys to take stuff down and you know that.
And he was like, no, I don't think so. I don't think so. Was
this live? This uh this was live a while the mod queue would
get so full about the Hassan community and the GG community arguing.
They just did not want to deal with it anymore. It didn't have
anything to do with them not liking Hassan or them liking Destiny.
How did you just go from I had no idea what that was for all
the way to just giving a full fleshed out answer for why it was
no no no no no that that was why they did not allow Hassan in
the He's talking about the blanket policy with the reason for
the policy was. Destiny clips when I first got there. Okay, so
then you did know what the ban was for. I I That's what was the
ban was for. I didn't know What What are you trying to say? You're
saying about that one like specific instance about Hassan.
Him trying to get it banned. No, I did not know Hassan was trying
to get his stuff banned cuz I wasn't there or they weren't contacted.
Or they weren't contacted specifically.
Sorry, I tried to get that all out one sentence. I got it.
Not easy.
Here, I mean grab something to respond?
Yeah. Oh, well, hold on. You got his Anth Anth is another moderator,
isn't it? We got two LSF mods. Should we pull the two LSF mods
in? Get their thoughts on this real quick or do we need to watch
a little bit more till they get to the end of this argument?
We'll get to the end of this argument here. This is all just
like the most AIDS level of drama, you know.
Uh yeah. Fun. Do you have another suggestion, Kelly Jean, or
No, no, I'm just Oh, thank you. Thank you. I look Anth left because
of what Kleiman said. What the hell? Look Kleiman, look what
you're doing. You're destroying content. Wow. Wow. yeah. Great
contribution. Thanks for watching. Okay. um So, chat chat chat
chat chat. Chat, I want to I want to hear what chat thinks though
real quick.
What What What's your opinion on The eth guy is in here, too.
Who won? Destiny, Tibold, do you think Do you think this conversation
was useful? What's up? What's up? Nobody brought that up. This
is actually the dance kid. Chat one. Chat one. Chat one, yeah.
Sorry. Yo, Dan, I was in the bathroom, so I might have missed
what you said. What you said? I'm sorry. Apparently, I ignored
you. Nothing.
Uh everything is fine. Cool. So, Dan, um do you have any You're
You're a very interesting character. You got a lot of issues,
right? With Twitch and the streaming atmosphere or whatever.
What's What's on your mind right now? What do you not What's
wrong with Twitch? What's wrong with streaming in general?
Man, it's uh it's rough out there on these streets right now,
you know? I don't know.
Man, these uh Dan Clancys out there, he's just doing whatever
he wants to do. No repercussions. What's your like actual like
so, do you think Dan Clancy is actually a bad CEO and he's destroying
Twitch or Without a doubt. He may be Skype levels of bad of of
a CEO. Bro, why'd you really get into SKYPE LEVELS. SKYPE LEVELS
OF BAD. OH MY GOD. Why is he bad? You know, I would say the reason
he's bad is that he's not good at his job, but I don't even know
if he [__] does his job anymore. All he does is like
Tik Tok dances with like 18-year-old [__] Asian women.
I feel like Dan Clancy is just a figurehead.
It is. crazy. So, what would be wrong with like uh someone maybe
like 35 plus hanging out with 18-year-olds, Dan? Have you got
a condemnation for that?
Dan, how far is your daughter away from 18, exactly? Okay, would
you rather be hanging out with Nazis, Queenie? Good. Dan Clancy
be hanging out with Nazis, Queenie? Answer the question. Would
you rather your Would you rather your 18-year-old daughter hang
out with Nick Fuentes or Destiny? Be honest. Be honest.
Be honest right now, both of you. Go. That's 100% Fuentes I mean,
she's totally safe with Fuentes, right? It's not even close.
Okay. Okay, we're going to compare Fuentes to anything Trump
has done and Trump's president. Fuentes has
has done his polling compared to Trump. Excuse me, Donald Trump
is our president. I don't think it matters who my daughter hangs
out with. He are
But it's it's it's go on people's streams. It isn't No, it comes
off bad. He is he's incompetent is what I would say. Uh but it
seems the entire staff at Twitch is like how do you let it be?
Like like forget everything. Okay, forget everything you know
about Twitch. Here's all you know. There's some annoying [__]
slumlord Jew that won't shut the [__] up about Twitch.
So, you're like, you know what? [__] it, let's ban
this But then you do that. Jesus, Dan.
Oh, that was a hard J. That was a harsh J. What the so incompetent
so [__]
Okay, I can say this I watched one or two Fuentes clips in my
time. I don't know if I've heard him hit that quite that hard
before. Jesus Christ. That not only do you not ban him and delete
his account, you keep charging his subscribers so he has future
dirt against you, and you don't delete any of his content so
that you violate GD PR. You do a full email trace. Wait, what
what is it? Wait.
Fuentes' daughter or Lolly and Joey's son. Fuentes' daughter
or Lolly and Joey's son. Uh
future dirt Uh I can't. I can't. And you don't delete any of
his content so that you violate GD PR. And he you do full a full
email trace of this whole thing. How [__] of a company
are you to do this? And the answer is very
But uh it it so Bro, there's a clip section and only Destiny
is under it. Okay, great. I can't wait to answer
What's going on with that bet against that Dan Clancy will lose
his job. Oh my god, is this what he wants to ask? How long do
I have? I I I I We all like I'm unfortunately we all know why
Dan was banned, right? Just don't talk about having pictures
of Dan Clancy's kids. Like I'm sorry, you talk about having pictures
of Dan Clancy's kids. That's just probably over the line. That's
probably something they could call extreme harassment. Hey Dan,
I've got pictures of you and your kids on vacation. I just That's
too far. It's too far. Tell me. I I God, it's Listen, the thing
that he didn't know is that I already dress up as a cat for free.
So he's really the loser in the I win either way, honestly. I
don't think so. That's not a win. I I I don't think so either,
but you know what? The cat boy stream will have to be what can
happen. There's nothing I can do about
Wait, it's not just a cat boy show. He's got to wear that cat
suit or anything else, like every episode, no? I think he's got
to wear it every episode. That was the agreement, wasn't it?
All of his future appearances on everything, he wears the cat
suit now? Or am I am I lost there? I'm positive that's what it
is. But Dan, also I I got to ask you cuz we have a lot of people
in chat who are just like calling you and Destiny out for whatever.
What's your what's your what's your response to them for being
for being like a cover-up artist and etc. etc. What do you what
do you say to that? Cuz people are going to ask you every single
time you come on the stream. Yeah, people ask every time I go
anywhere. Not a cover-up artist. I Steve's my friend and uh letting
it play out in the courts. That's that's it. I don't know. Like
everyone else out there like if they had a [__] just
said no comment. Let's just keep talking about killing people,
okay? Let's just keep talking about killing people, maybe eventually,
you know, nobody will have any objections. family member that
was accused of something,
you know, if they would immediately drop them or like a friend
or something like that, that's on them. Like I'm Yep, that's
that's my statement on that. All right. I love This guy's a real
drama stirrer. This guy's a real drama stirrer. Dan, what do
you have to say about people saying you cover things up? I can't
believe the drama there. That was crazy drama stirring right
there, wasn't it? He just loves engagement farming. That's the
That's what he loves drama stirring. He just stirs the pot all
the time. Dan, I've heard something about you covering a thing
up. Any idea? You want to just take that in any direction you
like. like I think that's pretty reasonable. Yeah. So so we're
we're we did Dan Clancy. Do you think Twitch How Oh, it's not
fun now, I guess. dog and do you think that's Uh yeah. Oh, whoa
whoa, yeah. Okay. Well, no, he just sticks by his friend. Okay,
based. Cool. Actually chance like it goes under some or somebody
buys it. Apparently, yo, time out. Apparently, Yo, we were asked
this question like months ago. Are we like seriously doing this?
And Logan Paul are in a investing group that are trying to buy
Twitch. I read that on a clipped season, I think. Could be a
lie cuz they kind of lie sometimes, but that's what I read. So
like Adin Ross buys Twitch. I think that you miss understand
how much money that Adin Ross No, it's an investing group. So
Logan and Adin would be like the faces, but there there's like
there's there's probably billionaires in there or something,
you know, it's not it's not like just Logan Paul. You know how
they do like the figurehead Magic Johnson with the, you know,
Dodgers. Like that kind of thing. Yeah, I understand that. Amazon
internally values Twitch at Well, they did before I got in there
at over 40 billion dollars. That's crazy. Okay. Now,
I don't think Twitch is worth that. Twitch is
garbage. I think the real value of the company is less than It's
probably in the in the 10 billion or less level. I mean, you
would have to look at it compared to Reddit, but Twitch is like
completely
on life support as a result of Amazon. Like Amazon supports it
across the board. There's staff that's shared across the companies.
There's like, you know, Twitch uses Amazon's infrastructure,
right, to do its stuff. Twitch Prime is literally Amazon Prime.
Like at every direction you turn Twitch is losing money and it's
kind of funny that YouTube has grown, TikTok has grown, and Twitch
is losing traffic. So, that tells you something about the
the company culture, tells you something about the staff there
and the way that they do things. And I'm glad and I hope that
it goes to [__] And I hope that Kick or Rumble or
Yeah, I mean realistically speaking, I think the most likely
person to buy the company is going to be some gaming company.
Like I think that it will be a
you know, it could be Sony.
I think it's an issue of the people running the company. There's
probably 150 people talking about the Jews
Hold on. Do you think their ads are actually gone? Like what's
up with the ads? Do you think your uh Twitch apocalypse thing
worked or kind of worked or is in the process of working? What's
up with that?
Well, I don't think it was my thing. I think it was everyone's
thing. No way he tried to back off that. Hold on. Did we just
catch that? Did we just We all caught that together, right? We
all caught that together?
Hold on. Dan, do you think your Twitch adpocalypse thing worked?
Yeah, I think it's not good. That's why it's going to [__]
Okay, do you think you had any effect on like on this happening?
Do you think you had any role? Do you think their ads are actually
gone? Like what's up with the ads? Do you think your Twitch apocalypse
thing worked or kind of worked or is in the process of working?
What's up with that? Well, I don't think it was my thing. I think
it was everyone's Can you guys say it wasn't Dan's thing, right?
Dan was not leading like some kind of Twitch adpocalypse. Dan
wasn't really involved that much, I don't think. I think Dan
was kind of hands-off on that, no? I will say it's unless you
two seconds ago he he said and they valued at 40 billion dollars
before Before I got my hands in there.
So, do you claim it or not? We try to dodge all the heat. That's
amazing. That's amazing. Okay, there we go. That was
not pleased Wait, wait. Kind of worked or is in the process of
working? What's up with that? Well, I don't think it was my thing.
I think it was everyone's
That was
not pleased with the way that they were
promoting content. You know when it hits differently, okay? So,
when you go to Rumble and there's some [__] path
that's talking about the Jews running you know, thunderstorms
or whatever, it doesn't hit the same if you turn on PBS and there's
a dude there saying that the Israeli flag is the same thing as
the Nazi flag, right? Cuz you expect one of these things to be
a little bit more balanced and fair and guarded, right? And that's
the problem with Twitch is that Twitch only allows like the
And I'm I'm a liberal, okay? But they
Like if you're not full-on Israel are nothing but Nazis and they
all have to go back to Poland or whatever, then yeah, you just
don't have a space there. Realistically speaking. And if you
do, you have to [__] beg
to get you back there. Like God knows what Aiden had to go through
to get unbanned on Twitch. Apparently a lot. Apparently a lot.
But Aiden so As far as did they lose money is what we did. The
answer is absolutely yes. How much? Um Okay, now as far as what
we did. Okay, maybe he just didn't understand the question when
he was like, "I wouldn't say it was buying." I would say hundreds
of millions.
To a point where if you go look at their
so twitch.tv/ads.txt,
you pull that up in archive.org,
you'll see that this is a company that historically has never
really used any
ad serving whatsoever. And
basically when we started they had to completely switch over
and now they're using they're using Magnite, they're using multiple
sources.
Um go ask your streamer how much money they made in December
compared to June. All of them are going to be like, "I made the
same or less." They're supposed to have made double, triple.
Uh So why hasn't any So So there were moments where like streamers
were coming out and being like, "My, you know, ad revenue is
low." But like after like that month, it's I haven't heard really
anything besides maybe Hasan. But like Hasan's rich as [__]
he doesn't care. Right? He does fine, I think. He's got to show
Hasan got hurt the most. Hasan can't run ads anymore and uh But what
about everybody else? Um I think that if you're in politics or
just chatting, you're [__] right now. Uh and that's
pretty pretty easy to ask. You can just go ask anyone in those
categories. I feel like that was inevitable. The stuff they talk
about, politics in general, like they were making money from
like Coca-Cola and [__] like saying crazy Even even
like I I agree with them politically, you still say crazy [__]
right? Like so Yeah. Um
I mean, there's still there's still ads on Twitch. I thought
there'd be some interesting stuff on here. Sorry, if that was
mean, bro, I'm sorry. Like I'm not trying No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. I I respect what you're doing. I don't think you do,
man. I enjoy the content. All right, I forgive you. I can't I
can't pull another moderator or down. Oh, that's unfortunate
that you're like, "I I respect what you're doing." He kind of
threw you entirely into the bus, Tibold. Oh, we're very very
Yeah, that's what Yes, we are. That's rough. Um yeah, that's
rough. Hey, it was cool talking to Destiny, too. So, have a good
night, guys. Be careful, buddy. Oh, [__] he's still
in here, I didn't know. All right, um I'm trying to find this
in tweet. I need to log in to my account, so give me a Okay,
which which one of it is it? The one about uh